Hi everybody, welcome to our second mini course in
machine learning. This sections going to be on unsupervised learning.
>> That sounds fun. Hi Michael.
>> Oh, hey Charles, I didn't even know you were here.
>> That's because I'm not really there.
>> Oh. [LAUGH]
I'm glad to hear your voice regardless.
>> Good, I'm always happy to hear your voice
Michael, and I'm looking forward to hearing about un-dash-supervised learning.
>> Well, unsupervised learning's going to be a
series of lectures that we do. But today's lecture Is on PZTTMNIIAOOI.
>> Ok...
>> Which is randomized optimization. I took
the letters of "optimization" and I randomized them.
>> [LAUGH]
You're such a nerd, I love it! Okay.
>> Alright so so the plan is to talk about optimization, and
in particular to focus on some algorithms that use randomization to be
more effective. But let's let's talk a little bit about optimization
for a moment, because that's something that has come up, but we
haven't really spent any time on it. So, what I'm thinking about,
when I, when I talk about optimization, I imagine that there's some
input space X, which is, you know kind of like in the
machine learning setting and we've also, we're also given access to an
objective function or a fitness function, F, that maps any of the
inputs in the the input space to a real number, a score.
Sometimes called fitness, sometimes called the objective,
sometimes called score. It could be any number
of things. But in the setting that we're talking about right now, the goal is to
find some value, x*, I didn't mean to put space, such that the fitness value for
that x* is equal to or maybe as close as possible to the maximum possible value.
>> So that's like [INAUDIBLE] like we were doing with [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, exactly, right. So of all the possible x's to choose, would we like
to choose the one that, that causes the function value to be the highest.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, I, I wrote it this way, though, because I thought
it would probably be helpful if it's like, yeah, because we'd be
pretty happy with the with an x* that isn't necessarily the best,
but it's like near arc max, right? Something that's close to the best.
>> Okay.
>> So,
so this is a really important sub-problem. It
comes up very often, I was wondering if
you could think of examples where that might
be a good thing to do. Like in life.
>> Well, Like in life.
>> Computation, which is life.
>> Computation is life. And life is computation. Well, believe it
or not, I was actually just talking to someone the other
day who's a chemical engineer and works at a chemical plant.
And he says there's all these parameters they have to tune when
they mix their little magical chemicals. And if they do
it just right, they end up with something that, you
know, is exactly the right temperature, comes out just right.
If they're wrong at all, if some of their temperature is
off a little bit or anything is wrong, then it
ends up costing a lot of money and not coming
out to be as good as they want it to
be. So, you know, factories and chemicals and optimization and parameters.
>> Factory,
chemical. I'm not sure that's a general catergory of
problem but I guess, I guess, maybe the one way
to think about it is We'll call it process
control. So if you've got a process that you're trying
to put together. And you have some way of
measuring how, how well it's going, like yield or cost,
or something like that. Then you could imagine optimizing
the, the process, itself, to try to improve your score.
>> Okay. Yeah I think that's what it is.
>> You know route finding is kind of like this as well. Right.
So just. You know, find me the best way to get to Georgia.
>> What about root finding?
>> Oooh, I see what you did there.
>> Mm mm.
>> So you could think of root finding as being a
kind of optimization as well. If you've got a function and
you're trying figure out where it crosses the the origin. You
might add you might set that up as a optimization problem.
You might say well of all the different positions I could
be in, I want to minimize the distance between the axis
and the value at the point where I chose it. Find
me the best one. Which, you know, is going to be right there.
>> Actually, you know, when you put it like that. How about neural networks?
>> Nice. So, that's, yeah let's get it back to the
learning settings. So, what is, what do you mean by neural networks?
>> Well, I mean,
everything we've been talking about so far. X, you know is some kind of stand
in for parameters of something. A process or
I don't know whatever. So if the weights
are just parameters of a neural network, then we want to find the x that
I guess minimizes our error over some training
set, or, or upcoming test sets or something.
>> Yeah, so minimizing error is a kind
of optimization. It's not a max in this case,
but if we I guess, negate it you want to maximize
the negative error, that it's maximized when the error is zero.
>> Right.
>> Cool, is any other learning related topics that
you can think of that, that have optimization in them?
>> Well I would guess anything with
parameters, where some parameters are better than others
and you have some way of measuring
how good they are, is an optimization problem.
>> So, decision
trees?
>> Sure.
>> So, so what's the parameters there?
>> There the order of the nodes, the actually
nodes, like what's the first node? Yeah, the whole structure
of the tree. So it's not a continuous value like
a weight, but it is a structure where we could
try to optimize over the structure. There's nothing in
the way that I set this up here that makes
it so that X has to be continuous or anything
like that. We just need a way of mapping inputs
to scores.
>> Okay. So all of machine learning. Everything we
did in the first third of the class is optimization.
>> There is some optimization in each of the
pieces of it. Yeah, exactly. because often what we say,
given this training set, find me a classifier that does
wel on the training set and that's an optimization problem.
>> Hmm.